yeah welcome to this video playing
Yardbird yet again it's one of the most
common opponents here and we have a
jungle going on he's gotten the American
flag probably being on a vacation or
something okay and you're only 93 and as
usual i forgot what i recommend it okay
so this one I think you played the Sun
against me earlier okay let's hope that
this isn't isn't too bad just tried with
with normal moves
what I need to be cautious with this
with this always with this Bishop only
for as long as I'm setting up this pin
nothing really terrible can happen to
the bishop but if he's got there should
be two castles then there might be some
sneaky night move and then a three and
my bishops trapped so this is something
to consider when I was one of aiming at
is is to play rook e8 rupee 8 and
possibly night fa to g6 but okay with
Bishop f5 he prevented that but now can
I can take now right it's not bad and
Knight to e5 maybe
25 yeah why not why not so I can now
capture and may be nice no no no this is
important 96 you can take F 695 so I
need to first first take him okay is
night before i move not probably not no
can take the d8 and c7 if everything
else fails okay so nigh g6 you will
probably take f6 and damaged my power
structure and I don't like that Queen
d70 can take age 6 it's also a bit a bit
uncomfortable so b6 come on f let's
let's just go p6 first make sure you
cannot place if I if I think about this
next move it's a bit uncomfortable on
this position
yeah probably a good strengthening move
preparing 96
you can go nitey 32 d5 this is of course
a drawback of the b6 move I can take h6
mm-hmm
wow this is really uncomfortable and to
rook e8 was was a really stupid decision
yeah just that just a passive position I
should before I could kill him tribe and
yeah I could even try a it's just a just
a good news wow wow this didn't when
didn't go too well yeah he's just a good
player I mean to for 40 years so it's
really a not really doing it justice so
usually just much stronger
yeah I don't really know what to do in
this position it's just terrible she's
sick so maybe I can can manage c6 but it
doesn't really doesn't really make it
any more attractive
yeah my hopes of survival are very very
low here especially considering what
kind of player this guy is just an
excellent attacking player okay not just
me five yeah but what what can you do it
was it was just a crap position anyway
that's any way to to defend it
yeah both moose win
it takes with the pawn yeah well this is
also winning e66 just blow no way to to
defend against e6 yeah okay come on
reside resigned yeah this was really bad
it's done don't think that the at the
beginning I wasn't too bad I mean it's
not possible that black as much worse in
this position I cannot cannot believe
that it's just a matter of precise
precise move orders maybe it was young
it starts around here probably where I
get into troll need to take him hmm you
have the interesting point is that after
Queen takes I have this idea like this
interesting okay I went for that and now
yeah this is slightly uncomfortable
already it's just the combination now
this this night is strong and somehow I
cannot really get out of this
yeah here thought the worst should be
should be over somehow but it isn't it
really isn't I mean especially after
that young could have played a form also
immediately yeah of course this weakens
the the dark squares terribly i was
aware of that but how can you stand this
night all the time now I was just out
Lee out played here gap this is just
just completely dead so this kind of
this kind of formation is really am
really uncomfortable yeah also you could
could argue that maybe I should after
after this I should instantly retreat
him and cover this maybe this was a
tough away to defend but it's already
it's a bit uncomfortable I can avoid all
this by am by capturing first this is
just better yeah but he played this
nicely I really look bad in this game
thanks for watching